Hey, kid!
Stop it.
Na-na na-na-na!
You can't shoot me!
- I'm underage!
- Dazzle, come in.
Bike theft in progress
in the southwest alley.
Put your clammy hands together
for Moonbeam City's
top sky dancer,
Odyssey!
[cheering]
Cool rave, chill buzz,
dirty beats.
The only thing that could
ruin this vibe
is if I start questioning it.
Uh-oh, I just questioned it.
What if I had a panic attack
right now?
That could happen.
Okay, just breathe, relax.
Oh, God.
I need some air!
Society made me this way!
I'm the product
of a broken fam--ah!
I'm not high, I swear.
Please don't call the cops.
- Arrest him, Dazzle.
- Whew!
You're under arrest
for 13 counts
of whatever you did.
Mama Mia.
That's some spicy justice.
Welcome to Crimezappers.
I'm retired Police Sergeant
Vex Mullery.
Join me as I go waist-deep into
the seedy underbelly of crime
in Moonbeam City.
[overlapping chatter]
Shut your damn mouths!
Vex Mullery is talking!
It's every family's worst
nightmare: getting murdered.
But here's the story
of one family pooch
that would be doggoned to see
her masters stabbed to death.
July 17th, 10:30 P.M.
The Petersen family doesn't
know it,
but a desperate stranger lurks.
Luckily, the family mutt Shasta
has a bone to pick
with this boneheaded killer.
[dog snarls]
Ow!
(Vex)
In the end,
the dogged tenacity
of this mangy bitch
saved the day.
[applause]
We could learn a lot
from Shasta.
You're doggone right we could.
Ah!
Vex Mullery!
Crimezappers
is my favorite show!
Didn't you ever get
my fan letters
or the death threats
after you didn't respond
to my fan letters?
Thank you, son,
but I'm not here for you.
I'm here for him.
Would you let us reenact
the bust
of that bicycle-thieving punk
for our program?
Oh, that was nothing.
We're all heroes
when you think about it.
But yes, my answer's yes,
and yes, I will gladly serve
as your on-set
technical consultant, yes.
Or you don't have to come
at all.
No, I insist.
Just send a car for me.
I was involved
in the arrest too.
Yeah, that's cute, Legs,
but it's Dazzle we want.